*Musique*
Le Battle Royal c'est devenue trop simple gamin
Des tops 1 par ci, des tops 1 par là
En veux-tu ? En voilà !
Aujourd'hui une nouvelle difficulté va se présenter à nous
Essayer de faire top 1...
*Gros suspense*
Sur téléphone mobile
*Lunettes qui tombent*
En voilà une surprise
...
Eblouissante
Parce que les lunettes...
Oui j'ai compris
Les amis nous sommes sur PUBG
Ceci est une vidéo sponsorisée c'est marqué dans la description
Vous avez vue le truc... euh communication commercial.
Là vous l'avez vu, là vous le voyez encore mieux maintenant... voilà
Les amis en tant que youtubeur je sais comment ça marche un peu maintenant
Et je sais que dans une vidéo il faut toujours un fil rouge
Alors qu'est-ce qu'on va faire comme fil rouge?
Hum... *réfléchi*
J'ai trouvé !
Attention c'est très impressionnant et original
3 games pour faire top 1!
Nous incarnerons cet homme : musculature omniprésente
Coupe de cheveux très élégante
Style vestimentaire... sobre
C'est partie pour jouer en 1 contre 100, comme d'habitude
Les 3 premières Games qu'on fait sur PUBG contiennent énormément de bot
Pour ne pas tricher qu'est-ce que j'ai fais sur le trône ce matin
J'ai 3 games de PUBG mobile de manière à ne pas tomber contre les bots
Ce serait de la triche, ce serait beaucoup trop facile
*rires*
On va aller, chers amis à Pochinki
On va se régaler à Ponchinki, ça va être la folie
OK ? J'y vais !
...
Probablement le meilleur moment de la vidéo actuellement
Sous vos yeux
*Musique d'attente*
Nan mais on passe du bon temps là
Mais mec, en vrai j'ai trop de style avec mon caleçon et mon afro
Ok atterrissage contrôlé
On ouvre la porte immédiatement et  qu'est-ce qu'on trouve ?
Un pistolet, des munitions et une chemise noire
Ah ! Très important le style, tuer avec style c'est très important
Ah ! On a la poêle ! Ah on est bien...
Elle, elle porte chance. C'est un petit peu l'attrape rêve de PUBG si je puis me permettre la poêle
AH ! Y a un mec ! Merde. Paniquez pas, paniquez pas
*sonne*
"Entrez"
*tirs*
Il a vu mon afro, vous avez vu il a bégayé
Il a fait : "wouah mais que fais-tu ici ?"
"Tu devrais être sur le dancefloor des boîtes de nuit les plus prisées de la capitale"
Et c'est pas des bots, là c'est que des vrais joueurs
Non mais j'insiste, hein, quand je fais un kill j'ai du mérite ok ?
*ouvre la porte*
*se fait tirer dessus*
WO WO WO WO WO
Il est où ce bâtard ?
Ah, il est là, regardez, on le vois
Moi je propose qu'on lui n*que sa grosse mère
...
*souffle*
*tirs*
OULALA
Je veux avant de mourir faire top 1 sur PUBG mobile.
C'est mon rêve actuellement.
Wah ! Vous l'avez vu ! Vous l'avez vu, le sorcier ! Le démon de ses morts !
Ah, sa mère je suis pas bien là, y a un mec à droite et un mec à gauche
On est complètement pris en sandwich
Regardez, il est là. Il va venir ?
Han ! Il vient ! Oh merde merde c'est, c'est un ouf, lui
Il a des couilles en or. Faut que je le baise...
*tirs*
Oh il s'fait chasser
YESSSSS
Il y a un mec à gauche faut que j'y aille !
Oh le bâtard
*tirs*
Ohhhhhhhhhhhhh
Je suis obligé de me justifier mais c'est pas des bots c'est vraiment des joueurs
*tirs*
C'est moi putain
*Coeur qui s'arrête*
OK ça va mieux, merci papa de m'avoir appris à relancer mon coeur moi-même !
Y a plus personne là. On dirait bien que quelqu'un a ravagé Pochinki gamin
Et il se pourrait bien qu'il soit devant vos yeux si tu vois ce que je veux dire.
Appelez-moi le sherif de Pochinki
Oh ça tire dessus on y va ! C'est là-bas, c'est à l'Est ! Oh je le vois !
OK je prends mes couilles et j'y vais. De toute façon on a la poêle, on a la sainte poêle
On va se positionner sur ce toit. On sera indétectable.
Ohhhhh ! Nan j'ai pas rêvé !
C'est un bot ou quoi ? Qu'est-ce qu'il fout ?
Oh mais putain faut que je le nique qu'est-ce-que je fais moi.
On y va, on y va, on y va, on y va...
*Imitations de balles*
Agent 67 tu es maintenant mort
Tu as rien d'un agent en passant, allez, ça dégage !
Allez, on va au colis. Ça nous ramène au milieu de la zone en plus c'est très bien
OK le colis devrait être dans cette zone. Ohhhhhh vous l'avez vu je l'ai vu on l'a tous vu
Bougez pas, il va au drop il est mignon. Il est mignon il connaît pas le sherif de Pochinki
*Rires*
Oh le bâtard il est pile derrière l'arbre. On va l'attendre on va l'attendre
*Musique épique*
OHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHH
*Rires*
*Tirs*
Mais qu'est-ce-qu'ils font ? Nan mais faut quand même qu'ils jouent les mecs. Et je lui vole sa caisse
J'ai aucun respect ! Je suis un shérif, je vais ce que je veux je m'en bat les couilles
Les amis, petits bilan on a fait 7 kills
On vient de se prendre un arbre. Il reste 15 joueurs en vie. On a la zone
Et là je pense qu'on va rester en caisse et qu'on va essayer d'écraser deux trois mecs.
J'veux en écraser un... Par pitié
Naaaaan
Oh, t'es mort. Regarde le, regarde moi cette espèce de petite merde là-bas
Wohhhh
*Tirs*
Nan nan nan
*tirs*
C'est un joueur pro
Yesss
*Respire*
OK la boisson, le calmant
Ouh là je suis dopé comme un sportif. Y'a un mec là
*tirs*
Oh la la la la
Medic23 tu n'as rien d'un medic. Ni les soins ni le courage mon ami
Attends y en a encore là-bas, là ? Attends je vais me le faire lui. Regardez-le il est mignon
Il est trop mignon
Oh la la dans la tête
OK on est plus que deux. Le mec que je viens de tuer il tirait vers la droite
Donc le gars il doit-être vers là-bas. Oh mec je suis en train de faire une patrouille de shérif
Mon chapeau, c'est important il nous a porté tellement chance là
Il sait qu'il s'en sortira pas face au sherif de Pochinki
Ohhh OK ! Vous l'avez vu, je l'ai vu, on l'a tous vu.
T'es mort crevette
*Musique de duel*
*tirs*
Il est au sniper
OK attends faut que je me heal faut que je me heal
Je stresse les amis
On peut le faire. C'est le duel de sherifs
Je sais pas où tu es petite merde mais tu es foutu
OK je t'ai vu
*tirs*
*Musique de la joie*
Allez maintenant on donne l'argent, on donne l'argent pour le bon joueur s'il vous plaît
Allez allez tout dans le chapeau. On fait comme à l'église bande de salopes. Vous savez ?
Seul un vrai sherif est capable de faire un tricks pareil
Après un top 1
Je vais pas vous mentir, je suis un peu frustré d'avoir fait top 1 à la première
Ça veut dire que la deuxième sera forcément moins bien. A moins qu'on fasse plus de kills.
Avec des moves encore plus beaux. Qu'on écrase des gens avec des véhicules
Qu'on tue le nouveau shérif de Pochinki. OK on y va
*Musique so 1980*
Alors je propose qu'on s'équipe sur un son délicieux des années 80
*Siffle en même temps que la musique des années 80*
Attendez attendez pause pause wohhh !
Oh il m'a enculé
*Musique*
T'as voulu faire quoi ?
Je suis dans la merde
Y'a un mec pas loin mais il a pas compris ce qu'il vient de se passer
Oh mais il est là-haut
OK donc il y a deux mecs, un à ma droite, l'autre en haut
*Musique*
Me faire tirer dessus dans le dos, ça m'a vraiment surpris, ça m'a rappelé que j'étais qu'une merde et non pas le shérif de Pochinki
*Chante la musique*
Oh mais il se barre
Wouahhh
Faut que j'appelle Tencent, ce qui font le jeu
C'est sûr, ils ont truqué mon compte je suis qu'avec des bots
Son loot il est où ? Woh woh woh woh woh
C'est mon loot. OK je te vois t'es mort en plus t'es nul
Nos années 80 elles sont là
*Danse sur la musique*
*Se prend la chaise*
OK ! Je peux vous dire que j'ai la banane sur la tête
Mais qu'aujourd'hui j'ai aussi la banane ailleurs hein
Ah qu'entends-je ? Ça écoute de la musique des années 80 ou pas par là
Parce que si ça écoutait pas de la musique des années 80 je vais devoir intervenir
L'ennemi se trouve là-bas derrière le petit cabanon... Nous l'avons vu
*tirs*
*rires*
Oh mais il y a un mec là aussi
*Musique des années 2000*
Je suis désolé, je suis arrivé et j'ai entendu autre chose qu'une musique des années 80
Ça m'a très déplu. Attend-tend-tend-tend-tend
Y'a la résistance des années 2000. Attends mais c'est quoi cette musique ? Mais qu'est ce qu'il écoute lui ! Faut que je le baise !
Là y'a deux mecs je crois
Ah regarde y'en a un là-bas
*Musique des années 2000*
Mais pourquoi vous tirez au fusil à pompe à cette distance, c'est un bot. Ohhhhhhh
Il est tout mignon on dirait un Pokémon. Je vais te capturer c'est parti le combat est lancé
Je lance boule de pétanque
Et c'est fini. Vraiment trop mignon. Hop on le prend on le met dans la Pokéball. Voilàààààà
On va lui voler son truc. Alors bon ma direction la prochaine zone
Elle est loin heureusement que nous avons un véhicule. Où ils sont les ouistitis là !
Je me sens seul, je me sens triste, je retire ma perruque.
Attends y a une voiture là. OH PUTAIN ON EST PRIS EN CHARGE
Vas-y tire tire t'as raison tire allez bonne chance
Oh il est pas nul il est pas nul. Oh là attention
Oh le duel
Laisse nous toi. Putain on était en duel mec, tu fais quoi ? T'es pas réglo
Attends j'essaie de l'aider comme je peux mais ah ok c'est bon. OK on peut reprendre on peut reprendre
C'est bon
Il est mort vous pensez ? Est-ce-qu'il a tué notre meilleur ami ? Faut que j'aille voir putain !
JOHNNNN ! Je suis là ! Ah, je suis coincé
John
*Musique triste*
Nan, je vais prendre ta chemise grise assortie
En souvenir de notre amitié
T'es grands morts ! Putain !
Je suis coincé
Wouah j'ai une double voiture je vous baise tous.
*rires*
OK c'est bon
Vite y'a la zone
Putain. Oh la la je suis dans la merde. C'est pas grave on va plus vite que la zone
*Lucas est concentré, on le lit sur son visage*
Y'a de l'eau !
OH PUT**N !
Wouah tellement d'émotions dans cette game. Aller, un p'tit coup de soins et on y retourne
OK on va aller dans celui-là.
J'ai l'impression qu'il y a un mec dans cette maison
C'est, c'est moi qui a tiré
*Arrêt du coeur*
Oh merci papa. Oh il est où le colis ça peut être bien d'aller au colis là.
Oh un ennemi en moins tiens.
Oh merde ! Oh merde !
*Musique + tirs*
T'es qu'une merde !
Vas-y je prends la M24. Mais attends on est plus que deux. Oh putain si je le tue avec un snip
OK on va faire comme tout à l'heure on va prendre la caisse, on va faire des rondes
Mes cheveux sont tombés c'est pas grave n'en tenez pas compte
Ça arrive à beaucoup d'homme à partir de l'âge de 40 ans ou avant pour les plus malchanceux comme Oli ou Carlito
Oh il était là
Nan jures c'était lui, nan.
Il m'a explosé mes morts...
Mec ! C'est maintenant que se joue toute la vidéo... Est-ce qu'on va finir sur une épique victoire ?
Une grosse balle dans la tête au sniper ou pas ?
*Lance une grenade*
Est-ce-que la grenade l'a niqué ?
OK c'est maintenant
Il est grave bon putain !
Allez on tente
*tirs*
NANNNNN
OHH
*Musique triste*
*pleurs*
Chers amis, c'est la fin de cette vidéo j'espère qu'elle vous a plu évidemment.
N'hésitez pas à l'aimer si c'est le cas en tout cas j'étais ravi
De rejouer à un petit peu de Battle Royal. Merci à Tencent
Qui a sponsorisé la vidéo merci beaucoup à eux ça fera de l'argent pour financer d'autres vidéos
Et ça c'est très cool. Par exemple celle des 10 millions qui a du retard mais qui arrivera,
Ne vous en faites pas. Franchement, jouer que le Battle Royal sur mobile c'est très prenant
C'est différent, c'est plus simple, c'est un peu moins de Try Hard
Franchement c'est cool
Je vous fais des bisous à très bientôt, portez-vous bien
Au revoir !
*musique de fonds*